risky one against a good player in Mal
here come the leaps it's Tamaris in a
nice stop there by jar on his first test
of the game here comes G Sola given go
attempt with Drew o Conor now centering
play but doy there defensively and Max
doy starts out he's in the Middle with
KN back to the L great move great goal
welcome back Matthew KN missed two but didn't
miss his first chance t with the illness and
showing just great speed here it's do makes the
play though and stands up and Graves just gets
caught going to the inside I love this move
though an aggressive move to the inside but
once it looked like he was going to cut across
he chose to cut right back and look at Tristan
jar I think he's thinking he's going to cut
across he's ready to brace himself and great
hands the sends it in behind the net Gary
there with it the highest scoring golender
in the League this year moves the P there's
go good check it's Robertson in get marter
scores great job again of the pressure on the puck
carrier right from behind it's doy who creates the
turnover Robertson with the little stoper pass
that you can see Joseph gets a piece of it but
how about the hands of Mitch Marner a bouncing
Puck don't try to overh handle it actually used
the Rolling Puck to your advantage all he's got
to do here is get it up and over the glove he's
in so tight not much else to do and he flips
It Up and Under the comes across for Riley
down low Marner back to Riley shooting rebound
Jerry down and a big stop there off tamarus Tim
shooting that fronted by leang zahna and
Chris leang tried to work it out Give It
Away off the post Holberg come close here McAn
Stars Bobby McAn is first in the National Hockey
League is that one going to be a commemorative
one but it's just a good hard work shift three
or four times the Penguins had a chance to clear
it there's the one off the post he stays with
it nice little shuttle pass there for berzi he's
got his back to the net there's nowhere for berzi
to go a quick little stop up by McMahon a quick
release and there's a memory Forever Your First
National Hockey League goal back to the line it's
Eric Carlson and a nice toone stop there by Jones
oh coner taken out a four here early knocked off
the Stick of lerd and Jones has to bail the leap
out him to get to that rebound but then the
rebound is there and Pon comes flying through
and and Carlson intercepts that in a stroza from
Center wed down by Jones up ahead and a pass to
the L great pass by nice over in scor Beauty
and it all started with a pass from Martin y
Christen jar watch this play by Marner he's got
no speed standing still so he gets pressured by
the Dem puts the PO between his legs that opens
up the Middle Lane and just great patience talk
about a confident start for Max doy kicks the legs
up like he's going to make the shot and already
Jar's bitten and gone down Jones with the quick
Bel Mar with with the Nifty one between there's
Dad smiling so there's the Gordy how hat there
you go you got it you got 18 minutes left in
the second period withby FR and Jones has to be
sharp again around it comes and moving up his Ben
mul in an outlet cut off by martyr walking in and
off the post seven years in a row is entire time
as the maple Le he's LED each year the least
and assist it's it's being strange being this
far in and he's behind there's Riley neander
shot scores johnus in front power play goal
by nothing Tonto their top goal score was number
91 18 Power Play Goals last year for darar Chris
that goal there is just number two these kind of
plays just haven't been happening for him on the
power play but he does exactly what he needs
to do you win the draw get to the front of the
net get the adrenaline pumping pretty amazing
the work that they do going to say that looks
like an unbeatable team here's tamarus back
in again rebound and he fired that off commit
just fly there your goenda wins the draw in his
defensive Zone one little long stretch pass there
opens up the ice nice move around a forward
and Crosby and he gets the Second Chance the
the delich maybe got a piece of it a little bit
as well he made the first save did he get the
second last 10 seconds of the
power play 6 minutes to go here
in the second Gregor hands it
off for two he back to Gregor
scores one second on the clock left on that power
play to delovic able to get that one for tuy how
about this little give and go is that one up
and over power play goal the Lea back on the
power play you wondered what the alignment
would be they got the top unit up once again
here's Mar D across oh what a stop rebound and
tied up in front to delic another one is this
just the speed of the entry and a quick little
stop up there by neander back down low and doy
with a great pass across Eller kind of tried
to get boxed out on tarus but wasn't able to
get a piece of the fck and there's the P of n
Del come sliding across and just didn't get it
Crosby unable to reach that LE will counter Here
Comes Noah Gregor back in looking for his second
and stop going to go in no they're going to wipe
it out as it went in off Greer who bucked in the
Dum of it here's Crosby trying to reach for this
one he goes down awkwardly now it's going back
the other way but the speed of Greger he knows
he's got the Inside Edge here on F and Carlson
and he knocks him in so I I don't think it's
one of those plays that the contact with the
skat on the pad nothing here to say today that
he shouldn't be the guy in goal Here Comes dander
dropping it off Morgan Riley another post a lot of
opportunities to jump up into the play here's one
though as the drop pass the puszi opens up that
lane and great job by Morgan Riley of beating his
man up the Pittsburgh was some Z time against a
top unit L trying to settle things down got it to
MC out to nander with berzi anares Tyler bzi and
it's a tap in for William nander 40 points on the
year in their own Zone and how about this long
pass Again by MC the stretch pass catches the
Penguins deep looked like rzi was going to shoot
for sure look at the Del he still thinks that a
shot was coming instead at the last second KNE
Lander credit to him he didn't blow by stopped
enough and from a tough angle gets the easy
tap in fori looking the whole time waited it
out and in the midst of a busy schedule
not a bad time for that to happen oh that
off the cross bar think his tracking of the
puck has been excellent does this hit in in
just quick little shot from the outside
I wasn't sure if it hit M cave or not oh
man just over hard Jones can start to
celebrate as the clock will wind down
back to back Saturdays the Lea will post
shut outs robton Jones his first as a baple
leaf